the Hobart vile vineyards only grow
reisling grapes and promptly so the
longer the fruit stays on the vine the
more intense the taste of the wine but
when is the right time for the harvest
if it's too soon or not soon enough the
quality of the end product can suffer
the siphon stuffy optimal harvesting
window is very small the weather during
the harvest was problematic we had a lot
of rain and it was too hot rain and heat
means the grapes pass through their
different phases very quickly they go
from being mature too ripe to overripe
life went on association Godiva yuba
wine growers have to nail the exact
moment to harvest and villain vial has
the knack although picked by hand the
grapes are processed and highly modern
equipment quality says via doesn't come
cheap they harvest from their own
vineyards exclusively and don't buy
extra grapes from outside only the best
fruit goes into the wine
villan via took over the vineyard from
his father he's a trained wine grower
and developed an early taste for his
future
he's coming from now on mine I clearly
remember my first wine expect a summer
secretly tasting it it was a 1971 graven
bag Lake vintage with the wine number
7107 I made a note of that it was 1973
and I was 10 years old and I really
liked that wine I found it so
fascinating so I used to go and take
little sips of it and I soon came to the
conclusion that I wanted to be a wine
grower the valve in Sevilla dense avoid
the vineyard is a family-run business
villains wife Martina takes care of the
paperwork year after year their wines
are chosen as Germany's best but they
don't let the success go to their heads
be providing ya know desk we're just
managing what we inherited you see the
beautiful location of the vineyard it's
our job to manage what others created
and what nature gives us geschlafen hob
wanting a tour and scaped the vineyard
sprawls over 90 Hector's in the hind gal
region the cold and sunshine typical for
the area provides an ideal climate for
the Riesling grape rhythm vial is active
in the association of german wine
estates
yeah we represent the interests of our
region and we want to help reinstate the
image German wine used to have 100 years
ago German wines white wines in
particular used to be the most popular
in the world and that is the main
motivation for my commitment both at the
vineyard and beyond it online with
Fernando he better serve wine what he
knows the vineyard has been in the
family for four generations about mile
bought it in eighteen seventy five and
was soon shipping his wines around the
world William has all documents from
that era including menus from imperial
and royal dinners where via reisling was
served these are fermions in astonish
you are selfish deontology own this
family tradition has handed down and
nurtured although I also find it very
important that each generation leaves
its own footprints that it's who owns a
tradition should not become dusty it
should be kept alive bendik garden bin
the seller is full of wines ranging in
price from cheap to expensive three
years ago this highly coveted dry talkin
villainous Lisa was auctioned off for
5117 euros there are only 30 bottles of
it in total they're suitable for storage
so does this yet saina talkin bo knows
Daisy this this is a talking bathe in
the house Lisa from 1989 installed
although the bottle here is dusted it's
not one of the oldest lines this talkin
beyond house laser is only 23 years old
but it could be stored here in the
cellar for decades our
great-grandchildren will enjoy it the
Hobart vile vineyards produce just six
hundred eighty thousand bottles per year
although the demand is far greater